hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back put let's play I'm a
story did you have a key did you want to
make sure I checked everywhere in here
cuz I think there might have been like a
key in here or something or some reason
you know okay under the link well no
okay in the fire maybe no okay
hot nope hit this pot nope okay on the
bookshelf I have a fish ah-ha-ha-ha-ha I
knew it I knew it I knew there was a
reading we coming I can hear
okay alright okay alright getting either
I hate that room I hate that room I hate
everything about that room that room is
bad I'm gonna move bad news bears moving
on moving on
I got a rod I got rod I still have
nightmares about those horrible torture
cells so at least that's saying that
Emma survived this excursion talk about
spoilers
okay so much well I got not enough all
right so I'm guessing the last rod that
I need is gonna be down in the extra
storage area good good great goodness
great that's that's great
that's great he's way too rust in it
what course it'll work
nothing oil could do to a key that would
make it not work or make it work the
rusting key won't work in this state
why gotta find some oil to rejuvenate it
what game logic game logic anyway let's
find out what's over here
besides the freaky fountain ah what's
this then
Machinery Monken going in a few I got
the lab was well lit I felt strangely at
ease I read them yeah this doesn't look
good
that music does not sound good
ah okay that's where I put there looks
like I'll need to get three rods to work
this elephant get this elevator working
Trinity triangle for phase still need
more rods for this to work still need
more rods for this to work I don't like
that music I haven't heard that music
really oh my oh my oh my oh my goodness
Oh My Damn oh boy this odda sighs this
this is here doesn't not here doesn't
look good
this here doesn't look good at all
I don't like those noises I don't I
don't like them
it's freaky freaky freaky oh don't tell
me
ah-ha-ha-ha not the pit anything but the
pit oh it's good take forever lovely
lovely lovely lovely lovely you lovely
lovely lovely lovely lovely lovely
lovely lovely oh this is nice
what was that I heard some I heard some
I heard some hired some oh ohoh jar is
now fears you he's wired I'm really glad
I got that but that jar first shows I'd
have to come down here in the collector
that is this ha OH
jump-scare uh okay okay I was seriously
expecting something to happen there oh
man I was like totally ready for that
well I wasn't ready but I was expecting
it all right
well yeah thankfully the elevator
machine itself was in l.k condition it's
time to search more rods if you know
what I mean
I need more rods for the machine the
machine is Emma's female wrestling
league name
oh wait no splurt yeah that worked
amazing how that worked like that what
the huh looks like okay I got that
include your treatment storage
thank God the lab was well-lit I felt
strange ladies in there but my rejoicing
yeah this looks good what was that what
is that what is that what is that ah I
am going to pee my pens in here aren't I
yep yep yep yep ensign I know I'm not
crazy those damn armored statues I swear
to god they have a mind of their own no
one believed me though I'd but I know I
swear I'm not mad why can't anyone see
it they move around on their own shits
gonna no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
dude like I'm a biggie right here
oh no no
I don't read this 12 December 84 degree
like Simon is impossible to Canadian
right now yesterday the team and I are
finally to cover the overpower hidden in
the deep in the ancient tomb we explored
and in near complete dark still we saw a
door outlined with a bright light would
rot onto our tools and moved aside this
massive stone door aside revealing the
orb chamber the light we experienced in
that chamber is beyond any brightness
I've seen my life what's her eyes
adjusted to the light I saw forth and
was the first to lay my hands upon his
flawless service instantly I felt the
terrifying surge of energy flow through
my body from the orb for a Mona I was
stuck to the very place I said in cannot
move for some minutes later I dare not
speak too soon about this but I now come
to question the myth of the subject if
it is supposed to give the owner the
ability to accomplish whatever they
desire why do I feel such evil thoughts
in my head since touching it
I shall write more on the subject in the
next few days oh it did it did it - ah I
got a key why do I need a key for that
lock door that one you know you know the
one you know the one I'm talking about
right where they go right I go where
they go where'd he go where'd they go
where'd he go where'd they go where
where where where did they go Oh No
let me in please oh no no no no no no oh
run low cycle circle no no no no no get
up get up get up get stuck shine no I'm
gonna get this frickin door open right
now get it up get it open groove is to
opening right now good I did get it I
did
okay okay all right okay
they went away they went away it went
away it went away no way
no I did nothing in the linen give me
aah aah oh my god Adam got it got a that
and out of that this obviously was not
know
oh I didn't even read what was on the
loading tree I didn't even
oh something about being hunted by armor
statues oh I need a few seconds ah
ah ah oh okay alright I got the last one
I can do this
oh oh oh oh god ah man
oh boy hi hi face hello there hi I just
need to stay in this all right I'm going
I'm moving forward oh my hands are
tingling
oh all right let's just get this done
yeah daddy you know there should work
now okay
all right
yummy oh that's good it's filled with
blood now what is that what is that what
is that what is that why why comparing a
note stay away from my or Bama you don't
stay away from our or Bema you don't
know what you're getting yourself to do
this crew you don't use all of them
yup yup nope
yo yo yo I'm gonna get your orbit ICU
which rule the video games will apply oh
it's gonna be a smooth transition I
remember myself thinking at this moment
well it's all
I knew what I had to do I just didn't
know if I had it in me to accomplish you
well if I only had the knowledge I have
now how things will be different
okay I think we're getting close to the
epic finale not that I like it oh all
right I'm actually gonna I think this is
I think this might be the end and you
guys know I want to keep the end in one
part so I'm just gonna end it here it's
only a minute early anyway and I need to
go run around my room or something to
pick myself back up so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotations
for mother Let's Plays that I've done
check other reaction compilations and as
always I will see you in the next video
but I